our top story this hour top U.S
officials are cautiously optimistic
about Russia's withdrawal from the vital
Southern Ukrainian Port City of kerasan
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
called it a big moment for Ukrainian
forces to reclaim the only Regional
Capital seized by Russia and a gateway
to Crimea but despite the major victory
Sullivan said the White House would not
push Ukraine for a diplomatic end to the
war Chris livesay reports
good morning this is just a stunning
turn of events remember Carson is an
area Russia was trying to turn into
Russia they had to fly the Russian flag
spend Russian rubles even set their
clocks forward to Moscow time but today
Ukraine is winding those clocks back
City the Kremlin ever managed to hold
today with Russia's chaotic Retreat it's
the liberated people of her song holding
each other rushing back into Ukraine's
arms with so much affection
it's slowing down their soldiers says
lawmaker Alexei goncharenko they're
being stopped by ukrainians by
ukrainians by just local people who are
so happy to see our army liberating them
that they're stopped with hugs and
kisses and people who are seeing in
Ukrainian Anthem with Ukrainian Flags
these are people who couldn't sing the
Ukrainian anthem for many months for
many months they could be killed for
this the people of her son waited said
president zelinski they were right to
pin their hopes on Ukraine
despite their first breath of freedom in
nearly nine months locals are still In
Harm's Way
Russian forces destroyed the major
Bridge as they fled and retained
artillery positions less than a mile
away on the other side they're also
known to leave booby traps in their wake
hiding landmines inside refrigerators
and underneath mattresses many civilians
have already died from explosives says
this Harrison military official there
will be said news from here song for
sure because every time we are
liberating our towns we are finding
tortured people raped people killed
people
but Ukraine is in no mood to lose
momentum
they can kill many more people
unfortunately that's the reality but
they're moving to a big big historical
defeat
so this is a massive embarrassment for
Russia oh yes of course strikes like
this one are always a threat and
remember the Harrison region is the
gateway to the Crimean Peninsula that
Russia captured way back in 2014. well
morale here is now so high many feel
they can take it back Elaine
Chris thank you you know his piece
really just underscores that
determination and strength of the
Ukrainian people and you see how
incredibly grateful they are as well if
this is still going on I think there was
a lot of you know the midterms this week
everything else a lot of people saying
is there less attention on Ukraine as
you see
um they're certainly not in Ukraine
right now right for those involved right
yeah and if they do continue to move the
Russians back what was it all for all
the Death the destruction
um the fact that they've been able to
rally is incredible really really
remarkable